let's go to our next caller from the 6-5
zero area code caller from six five zero
you're on I apologize I can barely hear
you I don't know if you've got me on
speakerphone or Bluetooth but I can
barely make out what you're saying yeah
sorry I don't bluetooth pairing them
that protocol I wanted to talk about
something other things that control this
time talk about the quote unquote black
washing of European history
like I say history student that's one of
the things but look at me right now is
uh make just like them putting black
people into roles in European history
that they were never a part of like
Achilles being black or Queen Margaret
of Europe being a half black woman and
when you say they who's doing this the
BBC and other companies so the BBC is
putting on articles saying people that
weren't black were black they're saying
no they're making documentaries and
movies and TV shows where people who are
not black or black in the brief for some
reason and why do they say that they're
doing that diversity inclusion and
they're knowingly making people black
who weren't black in real life yes Queen
Margaret was noted for being a fair
white skinned woman not a half black
woman I'm not I know it might come off
as racist but if I have a history
student there's certain things are safe
all right Genghis Khan was a Mongol it
was not he was definitely not why was
not black not tiny yeah let's say I
don't know that much about these
specific examples but why do you think
this is so important to you that like
this is what you called in Abell like
why does this issue why do you feel so
passionately about the issue of race in
this way it's as a history thing or I
study history and I'm becoming here and
when you mess up back by oh when you
totally would you miss the facts where
you politicize it without understanding
of it yeah
it kind of makes me pissed off it's like
oh it's just I got ran over the history
is for the history okay well I I
apologize I can't comment on I I just
haven't seen it but I will I will
research and follow-up I appreciate the
call and I I was sort of able to hear
you towards the towards the end there